i'm here with my culinary partner in
crime shift laura belden
[Applause]
now
keller and i had a very special
thanksgiving together that is actually a
huge centerpiece of our new cookbook
called rebel homemaker
and here it is it is the
thanksgiving
roulade
and
now we have our own magazine that's
right we do and actually the centerpiece
of it is this dish
because let's face it all magazines
around this time of year are trying to
show us inventive ways to approach a
thanksgiving meal so
this one has my heart i'm so excited to
share it with you also joining us is a
newly engaged couple your first
thanksgiving as an engaged couple
congratulations thank you
you've been together for two and a half
years yes good all right this is maria
colona
alex miranda
and i want to welcome you to our
thanksgiving
have you guys ever made thanksgiving
dinner together
we have not he has helped my family cook
he's an amazing cook
but we're excited for this year to be
engaged yeah yeah are you guys going to
spend it with family yes okay let's show
everybody this beautiful take on the
classic flavors of thanksgiving done in
this gorgeous gourmet beautiful way you
guys ready
all right so basically what drew was
saying we took all those flavors and we
stuff it in a rolled turkey breast so
why don't we start there with the
pounding out of the turkey
okay so
i'm very nervous so the turkey breast
actually comes like kind of if you
imagine it without the saran wrap this
way and you're gonna slice and then cut
through not all the way and you just
kind of open it up like a book
sandwich it in between two
pieces of plastic wrap how hard do i
pound it
not super hard because you know i want
to power
slightly gently yeah you're doing it and
you want to do outward motions basically
there you go an even thickness you're
doing great i like this dance move this
is going to be your thanksgiving dance
move okay i think that's great i am a
rebel homemaker so one last hit
so let's get to the stuffing so what we
did for the stuffing is again those
classic thanksgiving flavors we sauteed
shallots
and celery and garlic
and onions
and then mushrooms and as soon as the
mushrooms start to caramelize that's
what you have in here drew we basically
deglazed it with a little bit of white
wine and you're scraping those beautiful
bits up basically okay now i'm going to
add in some chopped parsley
chopped walnuts
and dried cranberries or cherries and
give it a good stir
and you're actually gonna lay the
stuffing in an even layer across of your
turkey breast that we've pounded out and
like you're gonna spread it all the way
to the sides completely flat and then
what you're gonna do
here comes the roulade part
you're ready to roll
do it all right so i like to use a
little bit of um plastic wrap underneath
that keeps things a little neat well
clean and then and also grippable
exactly and as you can see like i'm just
pulling it in
and rolling so you're getting this
perfect roulade
so you have your roulade here yes and
you're gonna tie it and all that does is
basically keep the roulade very compact
all right
and we're gonna actually so drew i
actually have a fully tied one and i'm
gonna start searing it off so we have a
hotband over here
and i'm just gonna sear
and all you're gonna do is basically
sear this roughly two minutes on each
side so two minutes four sides
all around and you're just looking to
get
[Applause]
well this is not how chefs do it but
it worked
and then after you stir it basically to
a golden brown
you're gonna put the glaze on and the
glaze
is just a little bit of tamari a little
balsamic a little orange juice for the
sweetness and
when that puppy is all glazed up
we're just going to add the less flavor
stuffing
on the side
and then you pop the whole thing in
325 degrees and it's gonna roast for
about 40 to 50 minutes until it's done
so until the internal temperature
reaches thank you
150.
you want to pick it up
you take it out all right perfect thank
you there we go
there we go
i'm going to bring it back with this
life
so how do you think thanksgiving is
going to go this year as a newly engaged
couple you go to one house for a little
bit and then the other house how do you
guys roll yeah so i usually stop by my
family's house first and then go for
dinner to maria's house
and we uh spend the yeah we have a big
blowout at my house yeah my mom and my
aunt do all kinds of cooking really yeah
my family doesn't cook so much but you
do a lot of cooking i do that he does
yeah yeah so my hands happy for the help
there you go
um okay
this is my favorite part
that looks so fun
can i eat you in a nice house
that is pretty beautiful
that's right
i mean look
look at how
absolutely beautiful this is
and that is at the end of the day what
it should look like
and then you can plate it really
beautifully um shall we taste it because
yes
that's so good
i'm gonna garnish for you it dressed it
up make it look nice and juicy
this is so good
well done drew
so
if you go in the cookbook or the
magazine you will find pilar's beautiful
turkey roulade that i am so proud to be
a part of and thank you for reinventing
thanksgiving for me pilar i really
really really really
really love this dish that you made
um maria and alex are going to stay with
us i've got a quick and delicious recipe
that makes a fantastic side it is lo-fi
and i guarantee you everyone's going to
fight over it we're making thanksgiving
dinner together as demonstrated pallar
displayed her gorgeous
gourmet turkey roulade because she is an
extraordinary chef
and i am a home cook so i want to show
you a dish that basically anybody could
make i love a traditional boxed yummy
low-fi corn casserole okay and this is
the dish that everybody's gonna be
scratching each other over
so
uh melted margarine
two kinds of corn canned creamed corn
and as i like to say niblets
all right here you have
your
corn
right out of the box right there you're
also going to incorporate two eggs
and sour cream i'm just going to follow
the instructions it can't be easier it's
one bowl
it's old school it's super classic i'm
going to get the whisk out because
that'll actually blend it better and you
just cannot fail with this dish and the
way i grew up is you know we ate
canned and boxed
corn pudding
and i loved it and
just where does he go
375 for 30 minutes
please and thank you
see you whip out like a gourmet roulade
i whip out some boxing canned cream
pudding corn pudding it's okay with us
and they go together beautifully they
really do check that out
also like if you're gonna make a giant
thanksgiving dinner you are gonna need
some sides
to be a little bit simpler
um
i'm going right in
and i think you guys have and you guys
have as well
all right
um this is my i'm going to go straight
from here thank you exactly
oh my gosh oh it's so
ugh
so moist so good
that corn
that's delicious do you like it yes
yeah it wasn't hard to make as you could
see it's not but it's so good
it's very moist
so
thank you maria
and alex
thank you so much everybody for choosing
to spend your time with us we make this
show for you
so take it with you
[Music]